et oui public
bahia personnes ah bon bah non il a fait
tous vivent maintenant il ya 150
chasseurs devant la porte
tu vois que la situation tu nous mets
que les histoires de tourterelles qui
pourra les faire ça chez bourin du
bourget et bien allez quoi 150 chasseurs
devant la porte le public a pas pu
rentrer en syrie valmy de 15,8 à cette
sortie rien pour toi la personne savait
que tu vas pas été occupée à point
de quoi doucher soeur mais quand ça va
voir ça or tous les soirs puis le 4 juin
joue une pièce de botho strauss au
théâtre de l'atelier qui s'appelle
personne d'autre la première fois qu'ils
ont entendu parler de botho strauss
jeudi qui rit parce que c'était à trois
ans c'était avant qu'ils sont remontés
radio et je vais dire que l auteur
contemporain allemand tüv raconte a
répondu que c'était la coqueluche des
intellos du théâtre subventionné mais
alors tu penses toujours la même chose
non mais c'est vrai que c'est un auteur
qui a été beaucoup monté ces dernières
années près et metteur en scène les
subventionner ouais mais c'est un bon
auteur d'ailleurs ils ont raison de
monter c'est quoi cette peur alors cette
pièce est une femme abandonnée qui
réalise c'est une femme de ma génération
mais qui à qui elle s'est mariée
classiquement à 18 ans sans doute enfin
s'est pas marié d'ailleurs mais j'étais
à la haye la rencontre un type alors il
fait semblant de faire les barricades
notre d'être comme ça révolutionnaire et
puis en réalité bon elle l a
complètement malgré les apparences
finalement elle a endossé au fond le
rôle traditionnel de la femme se dévoue
à l'homme probablement elle a travaillé
pour lui payer ses études etc etc
et puis bout de 17 ans le type sans
doute la baiser plus où j'étais pas elle
a eu le malheur d'aller voir ailleurs et
là dessus il en a profité pour lui dire
écoute regarde la femme que tu me fais
donc moins cher mais je m'excuse je
obligé de partir maintenant
bon avec une petite fectivement je me
marie avec la petite faune et là elle
prend tout sur la gueule
il veut plus la voir genre on ne doit
pas faire des scènes ça traumatise ma
femme ma nouvelle femme bon et elle se
dit c'est vrai vous 17 ans je vais tout
donner j'ai même pas d'enfant donc j'ai
rien rien rien
j'ai quarante balais et j'ai pas de
boulot enfin voilà et c'est ça et elle
elle se cogne la tête contre les murs
elle sait pas celle elle passe à tous
les états de la gamme tous les états
possibles voilà pendant une heure cinq
finalement qu elle s'est accrochée au
théâtre quand même un excellent si les
matelas plutôt l'a vendue en ans j'ai lu
un truc utilisé soit basique estime ses
plus terribles n'a me disais que c'était
mais en fait ce que tu comprends on nous
vend le truc au nord est de la violence
du sexe et tout mais enfin arrêtons moi
je veux dire si on parle de sexe vont
l'empiré des sens oui là on effet
j'apprends des trucs que je n'irai pas
faire chez moi tu vois même le dernier
tango je faisais une espèce de violences
sexuelles de choses dont ni la
franchement on se dit que c'était un
film marche et qu'on avec deux clips un
brut minou et c'est tout la confiance ça
tu le fais chez toi tu es cac mid 60
balles bah oui c'est vrai je peux le
faire moi-même s'agit 0 puis tu sais
comment dire le j'imagine site en prison
ou que sais tu as du mal en tant
qu'algérien à trouver une fille gentille
douce d'avoir effectivement je comprends
que c'est un petit peu mais quand tu as
la chance d'être temps qui offense et
c'est très bête
c'est très très très très très très bête
tu vois et moi il ya un degré de
conneries ou
au delà duquel je m'ennuie profondément
et puis t'as pas de télé non plus chez
toi ce qui paraît que depuis que tu as
été cambriolée tap a racheté la télé
mais parce que ça les scotchs les
aspirateurs sont que de serre estivale
si on pouvait leur [ __ ] détails avec
si on peut leur faire rentrer du sucré
comme ça te dirait que tu vois bon eh
bien alors du coup quand il veut plus la
télé pendant quelques jours ils sont un
peu désorienté son décroche oui non ils
sont en manque d'abord il ya ce vrai tu
vois alors il semble manquer crise
puis après une double ici on parle tu
viens sage en plus tu as dit
grandir c'est apprendre à renoncer c'est
bien au nom de la quarantaine quelques
j'avais dit ouais on étudie on ne peut
pas avoir le soleil et le temps dira sa
première venue c'est beau c'est à dire
hey daddy daddy's moment je fais l
admirable
oui tout apprécié la quarantaine quand
même oui hein tu dit manon c'est quand
on a 40 ans et ce qu'il faut faire on
connaît la valeur du temps tout ça je
n'ai pas d'avoir dit ça il sait qui je
suis relativement propre compte
quand j'étais parti tu as dit paris ça
pue ans a pu depuis toujours à zapper
budget du rhin ouais ouais j'ai du mal
non bah oui moi je me suis habitué tu
sais enfin moi ah bon toujours pas